Freunde wir haben dieses Jahr so viel
leckeres Essen gegessen das sturmi und
ich uns gedacht haben das müssen wir
ändern wir wollen uns gegenseitig etwas
zu Essen bestellen dass wir nutzen
niemals bestellt hätten und wir werden
nach dem schlechtesten Essen suchen dass
wir nur finden können für den jeweils
anderen natürlich kommt davon trotzdem
nichts weg erstmal Fred ich bin froh
dass du wieder hier zu Gast bist schön
Sie kennenzulernen schöne Küche wer bist
du noch mal ich bin der Freddy und ich
bin auch dabei
die neueren Zuschauer wissen vielleicht
nicht aber Freddy und ich habe eine
lange Vergangenheit du hast mich
eigentlich mehr oder weniger ans Kochen
auch ein Stück weit auf Youtube
herangeführt aber ich habe noch fünf
Videos gut weil wir ihm läuft gut jedes
Jahr darf ich mir einen einen Termin
aussuchen gemacht und heute habe ich
meinen Termin im Jahr nächstes Jahr
müssen wir zusammen machen
gesagt meine viererküche gegen dich und
deine besten Kindern ja genau ist Freddy
hat den Gast Vorteil du darfst als
erstes bestellen ich darf sie alleine
behandelt die Zuschauer gut ich gebe dir
mein handy geht nicht allzu viel Geld
aus und such dir was schönes raus oder
schlechtes genau wie ihr wenn ihr
nämlich jetzt noch Langeweile habt ihr
ein Like da lassen damit 30.000
bei 30.000 likes kommt das zwei gegen
zwei kocht Duell bei Freddy wow
aber 3000 likes also ich gehe jetzt
erstmal hier rauf machen wir das Leben
leichter denn wir können ja auf
Bewertung gehen und dann gehen wir mal
schön nach unten ich habe jetzt mal hier
runter gescrollt und man könnte das
natürlich hier zu Hardcore spielen wenn
irgendwas schlechtes bestellt aber was
Schlechtes muss ja nicht unbedingt eine
schlechte Bewertung sein das kann ja
auch für Max was sein was er vielleicht
gar nicht so feiert vom Geschmack der
ist halt sehr offen aber so ekelhafte
Sachen bestellen für die Tonne das will
Max nicht das will ich nicht deswegen
gucke ich mal ob sie vielleicht so
ausgefallene Sachen gibt wo ich
zumindest eine Geschmacksknospen challen
kann wo er sein geworden ist für mich
vielleicht was einfach weg ist was ich
aber vielleicht feiern dann können wir
nämlich auch noch gut weggeflogen oh
Gott mein oh gott sieht das ekelhaft aus
das ist nicht okay ich schau mal ganz
kurz durch die Liste ich bin natürlich
genauso wenig vorbereitet die Max Pizza
Alaska so so Hollandaise Lachsstreifen
Blattspinat Tomaten und Meer hinzufügen
Bolognese auf Lachs das ist sehr krass
das funktioniert wäre
es aber auch heftig weil dann ist der
ganze Tag gelaufen meine Freundin hat
heute Geburtstag ne wenn ich den jetzt
Gorgonzola Käse irgendwo drauf haue dann
ist aber jahrelang Sense sage ich dann
wird nicht mal mehr angeguckt Alter das
erstmal augenkontaktshop Gemüse Mix was
ist der Gemüse Mixer
das ist komplett
asozial oh mein Gott das sind so weißt
du wenn die places so wilde Sachen
schreiben an ihre Extras dann weißt Du
hier liegst du nur noch komplett falsch
ab wir haben jetzt eine Hot Dog Wurst
auf dem Lachs den Gemüse Mix und
natürlich noch ein Wurst dran weil ich
weiß Max und Wurst dran das ist im
Prinzip Max identity Karlsruhe das
gibt's hier Sauce Hollandaise Gyros
Fleisch Zwiebel Hirtenkäse noch mal
Sauce Hollandaise und Gyros Fleisch ja
mach mal auch noch mit rein Ring
Pizza Ring gefüllt mit beef Streifen
Peperoni Pizza Käse und Barbecue ja gut
ich bestelle das mal eben und dann sehen
wir jetzt max
gucken wir jetzt mal was das Ganze
werden wird ich sage euch so viel Freddy
war hier lange drin verschwunden und ich
habe die Sorge dass er weil einmal vor
vielen vielen Jahren haben wir das
gemacht hat der mir viel schlimmere
Sachen bestellt als ich ihm deshalb
hoffe ich dass ich diesmal auch was
üblich finde schauen wir mal rein was
wir so finden können ich hoffe nur dass
wir nicht das Gleiche bestellen falls ja
kannst du mir dann da dann gebe ich dir
einen Hinweis ja das Ding ist die
Restaurants sind alle nicht verkehrt ne
also was wir hier so haben ist
eigentlich fit so Enchilada ist der
schlecht am schlechtesten bewertete
laden und auch der gibt's ja in vielen
Städten ist jetzt nicht ganz schlimm so
deshalb will ich auf eine
geschmacksverlängerung gehen ich habe
eine Idee ich suche einfach mal nach
Bowl weil vielleicht kann man irgendwo
so eine Bowl Kaste Meißen und dann
könnte ich sowas super komisch ist
einfach zusammenbauen DIY okay iOS Style
okay
gar keinen Bock hat ja die Basis seine
Base sind schon mal Zucchini komisch ich
finde am komischsten
dazu gibt es rote Beete dann Grünkohl
andern über alles und Chili Soße zwei
Soßen die man hasst also diese
miteinander gar nicht passen aber
Erdnussbutter Shrimps ich nehme schon
auf jeden Fall mal Erdnussbutter und
dann
screencreme Mario mit Wasabi ja Topping
Sushi da und geröstete Zwiebeln dicker
das wird wirklich übel ich glaube das
wenn du das ist was ich jetzt fertig
bestellen werde dann hast du richtig
Bauchschmerzen ich bin guter Dinge ich
würde sagen wir bestellen und dann sehen
wir uns gleich zum Probieren ich
vernehme einen zarten Duft von meiner
Linken Sturm ist Bestellung ist da und
ich rieche das pizza-artiges deshalb bin
ich gespannt weil Pizza kann gut oder
kann schlecht sein ich habe schon so
eine Vorahnung wie es wird zeig mal her
was du bestellt hast ja such dir mal was
aus Digger was ist das denn
ich schwöre du bist einfach zu gut darin
Scheiße zu bestellen weil auch damals
schon ich weiß wer weiß also erstmal
muss man ganz kurz sagen die Leute denen
das hier gehört wir wollen jetzt hier
wirklich niemanden brechen ne ja aber
also es sind auf jeden Fall wilde
Kombinationen die die anbieten sagen wir
so viel ich bin gespannt hier oben sind
bestimmt sowas wie so Pizzabrötchen drin
ich sehe rote Zwiebel ich sehe Jalapenos
ich sehe Hackfleisch alter Schwede aber
was ist das auch für was sind das für
aperolos das Ding ist nur ich habe echt
Hunger und ich mir läuft trotzdem
irgendwie das Wasser im Mund zusammen
geile Sachen dabei wie stehst du zur
nächsten muss man ganz kurz anfangen
nicht schlimm aber in ihrem klassischen
Anwendungsszenario mit mag ich gerne
noch eine Reise vor dir kann ich jetzt
gleich sagen
magst du es gerne nö eigentlich nicht
also in so einer Kombination ist glaube
ich nicht schlimm aber ich finde die
Kombi will das was uns schmecken ich
glaube so ein fluffy Brot so ich glaube
das tatsächlich erstaunlich lecker oder
boah das ist ein Crossover das ist
nämlich genau die gleiche
Chili Cheeseburger hat auch eine gewisse
Schärfe aber nicht verkehrt Alter also
also noch bin ich bei dir das hat eine
Daseinsberechtigung aber es ist noch
besser wenn du besoffen bist also das
ist irgendeine Schachtel irgendein
Karton es ist eine Calzone ne überbacken
mit Käse
alter Schwede das sieht irgendwie aus
wie so eine Cheeseburger kelzone heißt
das zufällig so
sieht das Ganze aus oder ein bisschen
drauf drückt also rein in die Masse ne
fucking Freiwild Giraffe boah der ist
immer so jemand der so große Stücke
abbeißt nicht trau mich das nicht mache
immer so wenig um zu gucken wie ich
reagiere also auf irgendeine Art und
Weise ist das auch wieder richtig loki
ist es die gleiche Füllung diesmal
Hollandaise dabei schmeckt nach
Holländer also ich kann dir eine Sache
verraten und das ist halt glaube ich
überall Hollandaise dabei ne also das
ist schon so das ist so durchgehen so
falsch wie es klingt so schlimm wie es
aussieht ist das einfach
erwartungstechnisch deutlich besser oder
natürlich lecker ne ja das sage ich ja
die ganze Zeit zwei noch Pizza ist so
ein weites Wort die hat schon so ein
Gesicht
da ist die ist schon so das ist jetzt
nichts leichtes auf jeden Fall wieder
mal also ich würde fast so schwer ja
schau mal rein drei zwei eins
Bruder das ist so
ich muss jetzt schlechtes
saufen dieses Restaurant versuchen er
ist so schlecht wie nur menschlich
möglich aussehen zu lassen
so diese dunklen Stellen diese komische
Wurst na dann schauen wir uns den einmal
an boah ist das schwer das Ding das ist
irgendwie so eine Mischung aus dem Börek
Pizza und was auch immer diese Form hat
Alter ich dachte gerade das sei Reis
hier vorne
eigentlich war das was positives ich
dachte die Calzone scheiß mehr rein aber
die war jetzt halt voll das Meisterwerk
meine Freundin hat heute Geburtstag du
bestellst mir Aioli und Jalapeño und
Hollandaise und original das gleiche was
ich gerade im Video gesagt
Geburtstag
eigentlich würde ich das nicht essen
wollen aber weil alles so gut schmeckt
hat ich glaube auch ist es gut
es ist leider glaube ich echt ein place
wo man so richtig ranzig mal so ein WOW
haben sich mitgestalten kann ne das ist
eigentlich mein Licht Favorit bisher
weil ich mag nicht so gerne Paprika und
darin finde ich schmeckt die wirklich
nicht gut gut ich würde dann Abstand
davon nehmen dass jetzt weiter zu essen
das esse ich noch auf aber Leute die
Paprika mögen können das vielleicht auch
Paprika so ich dachte tatsächlich dass
der Burner das war eigentlich das
positives schauen wir mal rein Leute ich
erwarte das schlimmste ist
Lachs okay Lachs ist was anderes das ist
nicht dieses Foto machen
Spinat Mais Bockwurst was ist das also
es ist eine es ist eine Pizza ich kann
dir nicht genau den Namen verraten aber
ich finde ich bin hier schon den Weg
gegangen ist besser zu machen dass die
ein oder andere Wurst noch den Weg auf
die Pizza gefunden
nein
ich habe jetzt gerade gesehen die Pizza
hat einen Wurst dran die hat einen ist
das dein ernst
da ist nicht immer Tomatensoße drauf
Pizza wenn du das einem Italiener zeigst
der der muss dich damit er sich nicht
sein Gesicht verliert muss der nicht
umbringen es geht
nicht anders das ist wirklich ich bin ja
auch ein pizza-liebhaber ne so
gerne Pizza wir sind extra zum
Weltmeister gefahren und so aber das
hier ich frage mich wenn ich davon jetzt
ein bisschen nehme redet der überhaupt
noch mit mir wenn müsst ihr noch mal
Treffer die Weltmeister guckt euch an
Leute Cherrytomaten einmal rot einmal
gelb farbenfroh ist die Pizza auf jeden
Fall guck dann haben wir ein paar kleine
Samen bites rispy Fried sausage der
Gemüse Mix den ich da drauf gemacht habe
ich wusste nicht genau was es ist im
Rand haben wir die halbe Bockwurst
verstehst die Komposition noch nicht bis
du es gegessen hast
ich übernehme das gerne von Max kurz gar
kein Problem leute das ist so lecker
dieser Geschmack von hinten ich weiß gar
nicht wo ich anfangen soll das Olivenöl
mit dem der Teig gemacht wurde der Mais
wurde noch persönlich massiert von
francenico persönlich dem Kölner
Weltmeister
das war alles was gerade sagen wollte
also danke gucken wir mal was für Dich
bestellt haben oder willst du probieren
ich schaue mal was du willst
also hallo Freunde ich habe wirklich
gelitten ich hätte auch den Schritt
machen soll und dir ganz viel bestellen
müssen was scheiße ist weil du musst nur
einmal durch aber es wird auf jeden Fall
du hast gesagt dass Hunger ne viel Spaß
ja vielen Dank ach ist so ein Bowl
scheiße oder was guck mal das mit Fisch
hallo
Wayne okeyball superladen kann man gar
nicht sagen aber du hast das so selber
zusammengestellt
ja gut dann ach ja Meeresfrüchte und ich
ne wir lieben uns ja das liegt auf mein
Magen ne ja ja ja ist mal wieder hier
ein bisschen Platz Spinat wir haben eine
Zwiebel damit wir natürlich schwimmt wir
haben ein bisschen rote wieder oh guck
mal eine kleine Gurke das ist die Base
Nudeln oder ja dann haben wir ein
bisschen Ingwer mit Sesam noch natürlich
drauf so dann haben wir hier ein
bisschen
Italiener mögen das nicht
aufessen
alles
für sich bestimmt nicht so schlimm aber
ich finde so die Gesamtkomposition wird
glaube ich super rein
warum ist es so bitter geworden auf
einmal wie wie findest du die Soßen
Kombination wir haben nämlich einmal
Dream und einmal Wasabi Mario ah ja gar
nicht nur scharf so was habe ich Schaf
dieses unangenehme sehr schnell und dann
schnell wieder weg
also hinten ja also ich bin ganz ehrlich
eine Ananas mit so einem Wasabi
Geschmack drin und so rote Beete das
finde ich schon tatsächlich sehr
hinderlich aber gebe ich doch mal
unseren schlimmsten Chance würde ich
sagen
du wenn ich das jetzt komplett bewerten
müsste würde ich sagen das kann man gut
wegstecken das ist glaube ich nicht so
das Problem wenn du ein bisschen scharf
macht das ist so Wasabi scharf das
könnte ich mir so wegschrauben und ich
würde nur ein bisschen so Meeresfrüchte
halt so ein bisschen hier Shrimps
schmecken müssen
[Gelächter]
also die Dinger die schmecken nur nach
dem Dressing z.B den kannst
manchmal ein bisschen Ananas manchmal
ein bisschen scharf manchmal ein
bisschen Scampi die Zucchini Nudeln sind
echt Enttäuschung gar nichts ja also
dann nimmt noch mal jemand gerne ab sage
ich bei so einem Geschmack ob ich mir
meine Pizza ich hoffe dass euch das
Video vielleicht geholfen hat ein
bisschen weniger Appetit über die
weihnachtszarge zu haben wenn ich daran
denke wenn ich mitten vom Festessen
stehe dann ist vielleicht ein bisschen
weniger Freddy das war ein Traum mit dir
ist bitte noch den Tisch sauber den Rest
mache ich und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten Video wieder schaut bei Freddy
vorbei wie gesagt 30.000 likes und wir
machen das zwei gegen zwei Kochduell auf
Freddys Kanal geht nämlich davon aus
dass es schafft wurde 30.000 sehr viel
ist danke ich rede jetzt immer weiter am
Ende kommt damit
[Musik]
reicht mir jetzt hallo ich bin der
Freddy und ich bin auch dabei gewesen